this word I'm going to ask you to take a
look at Plankton's exhibit 881a
this is one of the articles containing
the counterclaim statements by Adam
Waldman is that correct
I haven't seen the article yet okay why
don't we go to page eight of this
article
Adam Waldman Deb's lawyer said
afterwards quote Amber Heard and her
friends in the media use fake sexual
violence allegations as both the sword
and shield depending on their needs
they have selected some of her sexual
violence hoax facts as a sword
inflicting them on the public and Mr
Depp do you see that yes I do is that
one of the statements that you allege
are defamatory it's defamatory
that's correct it's hard you're not
aware of any career opportunities that
you lost as a result of Mr waldman's
statements are you
well it's kind of hard to point to the
jobs you're not offered right the gigs
you don't get you were not replaced in
Aquaman 2 were you they released me from
my contract and and I fought to stay in
it and they kept me in it I just don't
know how much I'm in actually I love the
Final Cut
and you testified yesterday that L'Oreal
actually extended your contract in April
of 2020. is that correct
in part they extended it and held me
and you testified yesterday that L'Oreal
extended your contract again in November
of 2021 correct
not exactly they extended it because it
couldn't use me or any of the materials
for me
and that extension was for 20 months
right that's correct this is from March
26 2021 right that's what it looks like
yes and this is after he made the
statement you claim the statements you
claim are defamatory right Miss heard
21 yes Miss heard you tweeted at Adam
Walden quote yes Mr Waldman I may be
wearing makeup on this occasion but on
every occasion you will still be short
did I read that right
yes
we can put this down thank you
it's her extensive relationship with Mr
dab ended you have completed your level
three sommelier training haven't you I
haven't completed it yet
no I'm on level three
you also have had a baby right I have
and you enjoy being a mother
more than anything
still love to cook
I do
and you love to hike
I've taken a break on hiking for a
minute you have friends right I do have
friends you spend time with those
friends
occasionally when I can and you exercise
regularly every day
you just filmed a movie in March of 2022
isn't that right
yes the one I just shot in Guatemala
that I spoke of earlier and you have
um you had a major role in a major film
that's scheduled to be released soon is
that correct
Aquaman too
as I said I don't know if I will even be
in the Final Cut or how much I will be
it was difficult to stay in the movie
can we please pull up Plankton's exhibit
356
.
I can't promise you I won't get physical
yet God
I'm so mad at music
I can promise you I
like everything to change
it
and then I hope you leave me
nothing if I need to I will leave you
it's fair I can't do it you know and I
think honestly if we hold each other
accountable to that
Mr that's you and Mr dab on that
recording correct that's correct and you
told Mr dab quote I can't promise you
that I won't get physical end quote
correct that's correct he was accusing
me of instigating something in a
situation I explained yesterday
and you also told Mr dad that sometimes
you get so mad you lose it correct
that's correct I also explained the
context of that fight yesterday
isn't that exactly what you told Ben
King on your way back from Australia you
got so mad you lose it absolutely not I
know that that's what Ben King testified
to but I never had that conversation
with Ben King I remember eating it as a
response
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
as that audio is recording is being
played in your deposition aren't you
misheard not smiling because of the
audio I'm smiling because of what's
happening around me you even roll your
eyes at one point don't you I was
sitting opposite a whole table full of
lawyers who were snickering laughing and
rolling their eyes at me while I was
talking
is there something I'm using about
kicking a door into your husband's head
no I was rolling my eyes and commenting
on what I was experiencing at that time
in recounting the story there's
something amusing to you about punching
your husband in the jaw that is not what
I was smiling about and no I do not
think it's amusing Mr you testified
yesterday that when you left the
courthouse after obtaining the domestic
violence restraining order against Mr
Depp you walked out to quote a sea of
Paparazzi and cameras right that's
correct you testified that you were
surprised to see the sea of cameras
that's correct
because it was quiet when you went into
the courthouse that morning
and the divorce had remained under the
radar up to that point you testified
that no one knew about your divorce so
you thought he was going to stay that
way right no I always figured it would
come out I just
trying to buy time
you knew the media had been alerted that
you were filing for divorce right I
started no I just knew that it was
impossible to do that privately so you
could just hope it was a matter of time
you knew they were going to be there
didn't you no I did not
I kind of assume I assume since it's a
public building that there's that
likelihood or not likely a possibility
but um I was you know I was I was
shocked if we could please play and
display to the jury
plaintiff exhibit 1280
is responsible Miss heard did you send a
text message to Jerry judge on May 24
2016.
telling jury judge quote I'm desperately
trying to reach Johnny it's extremely
important please tell him
I remember
sending the text message that is in
front of me right now to Jerry
and I would like I remember sending this
because I wanted to tell Johnny or have
him told by Jerry or someone who knew
him or was close to him basically I
didn't want him to find out online that
I had or was about to file
I had already filed for divorce I wanted
him to know verbally so I was trying to
reach him through a third party
to tell him when I say reach I'm
specifically saying I would like him to
know information coming from me for
coming from Jerry for me
so that he finds out about the divorce
filing
or my intention to do so
from some other source other than TMZ
which was alerted
[Music]
he slipped up there didn't you misheard
we let it slip out that TMZ had been
alerted to your filing of the domestic
violence restraining order didn't you I
disagree that's not what I'm talking
about TMZ is the same outlet that you
released the video of Mr Depp attacking
the kitchen cabinets the day before this
deposition was taken wasn't it I didn't
do that I don't know how to do the
copyright to that video now doesn't it I
have no idea what TMZ did they pay you
for that
I never got paid for it because I had
nothing to do with that so TMZ was just
lucky in getting the inside scooped to
your divorce from Mr Depp huh
I have no idea it is not that's not my
area of expertise I wouldn't even know
how to do that
and also what does that get me if I
wanted to delete things about Johnny I
could have done that in a much more
successful way in a bigger way for years
now when you were extorting him for
seven million dollars I got a fraction
of what I was entitled to in the state
of California by the way what extortion
Tasha van reads your ex-wife right
that's right she's Mike's partner she's
the one that told
that you told this jury Mr Depp was
jealous of right
yeah well that was a 2013 fights in
around March yes you testified that he
tried to burn one of her paintings right
that's correct you testified he tried to
burn
um
one of your favorite paintings that she
did right
I don't know if it was one of my
favorites
you committed domestic violence against
Miss manri during your relationship
didn't you no I did not you assaulted
her at a Seattle airport in 2009 didn't
you no I did not and people saw that
that's not true and it was covered in
the Press
isn't that true it was a it was planted
in the Press by Johnny's team two days
after I got the tro
just heard did Ms Van Rey come out after
that article came in to make a public
statement it was false of course
objection your honor here say yeah I
should at least be overruled thank you
of course she did
now let's talk about the TMZ alerted
explain to the jury what you meant by
the TMZ was alerted
uh so when you make these kind of
filings meaning divorce uh marriage
things like that they are public record
and so when we file for divorce when I
filed for divorce I asked my team to
file in the most discreet way literally
to put it under a stack of papers and
file it at the end of day so kind of
hide more of a shot of being missed by
the paparazzi and by TMZ and those sorts
of publicity
[Music]
Outlets
I believe that we had been remarkably
lucky following the divorce that it
wasn't picked up and that it gave me a
precious few days
um of of Peace at that really fragile
time
when I found out that they were going to
run the story or that they had the
information I was
trying to get a hold of Johnny
to clarify
that I did not do this in a punitive way
I didn't want him to be mad at me I
didn't you know I didn't want him to
find out
in that sort of context online why did
James Franco visit you on the evening of
5 22 2016. objection calls for
speculation do you know yes please tell
us because he was my friend and he lived
next door quite literally next door and
I had frankly exhausted my support
network with my usual friends and was
happy to welcome as much friendship at
that time as I could possibly get
now the video showed him laying his head
on your shoulder can you describe for
the jury what the interaction was
without saying what was said what the
interaction was that led to that
he uh after seeing my face put him ahead
or calls for speculation that doesn't
call for speculation if she sees that he
sees her he touched this side of myself
okay again your honor if we can instruct
the witness if you could wait till after
the objection please all right what did
Mr Franco do
on the elevator before laying his head
on your shoulder he I'm gonna touch the
side of my face
and responded to what he saw